اكثر من دراسه تؤيد ظهور اول انسان في
القاره السمراء قبل انتقاله الى اسيا
واوروبا موقع
لدراسه عن معهد البيانات الضخمه التابعه
لجامعه اكسفورد كشفت عما يعتقد انه المكان
الذي يتحدى منه اسلاف كل البشر والنتيجه
المقاله التي نشرها الموقع تتحدث عن خريطه
كامله العلاقات الجنيه بين البشر حيث تمكن
العلماء من انشاء اكبر شجره عائله بشريه
على الاطلاق النتائج المحدثه ترجح باختصار
ان الجميع منهم على قيد الحياه اليوم ترجع
اصولهم الى بلد عربي هذا البلد هو السودان
وعلى كل حال لتقديم هذه المعلومات الينا
هنا في الاستوديو مراسلتنا في السودان
ولكن هنا في استديو صباح العربيه الريان
يسعد صباحك ريان
صباحك احلى نادين شجره العائله العملاقه
او اكبر شجره عائله في العالم تربط نحو 27
مليون شخص من حول العالم احياء واموات ما
يعني سلاله واحده تتعقب اسلافنا جميعا
وبحث اجراه معهد البيانات التابعه لجامعه
اكسفورد يكشفوا كيفيه ارتباط افراد العالم
ببعضهم البعض نجحت النتائج في استعاده
الاحداث الرئيسيه في تاريخ الجنس البشري
وتطوره بما في ذلك الهجره من افريقيا الى
اسيا واوروبا يمكن ان تكون للنتائج
تطبيقات في الابحاث الطبيه بما في ذلك
تحديد العوامل الوراثيه والمخاطر المرض
الفريق يعتبر ان شجره عائله البشر ستكون
اكثر دقه في المستقبل وست ستمكن الباحثين
انشاء خريطه واحده موحده تشرح اصل الجميع
التنوعات الجينيه البشريه التي نراها
اليوم
ومن الخرطوم سال الناس وسالنا السودانيين
على تعليقهم على الدراسه القائله بان
اسلاف البشر من السودان نتابع ردود
الافعال
السودان بؤره العالم واقع في منتصف العالم
ساهل دليل انه يكون
الانسانيه او البشريه ابتدات منه
اكثر
البشر من السودان الدراسه دي انا بالنسبه
لي
يعني ايمانطيه شديد لانه هو يشيل
التاريخ القديم همم او السودان من الدول
الفيه التاريخ القديمه يعني مثلا
الاهرامات في السودان في نهر النيل في
الفجراوي اذا هو فعليا في اتجاه بتع دراسه
من الافضل انه الناس تواصل في الدراسه
حوله لانه فعليا السودانيين محتاجين دفع
زي دي لانه احنا يعني طوال تاريخنا
الفائده من المشاكل الاساسيه القاعده
عندنا سرديه تاريخيه نبني عليهم
في الجوجل انه السودان اصلا مشاريع ناس يا
غالي
جامعه اكسفورد برده عامله عليه دراسات
حقيقيه السودان هيبقى يعني هيكون عليه
يعني هنرتفع يعني
في الاستوديو ينضم الينا استاذ عالم
الجينات والتطور في جامعه الشارقه الدكتور
عبد الله المطيري دكتور اسعد صباحك منورنا
في الاستديو شكرا على تواجدك معانا عندما
يتحدث دراسه ان اصول البشر جميعها من
السودان جينيا من الناحيه العلميه ما الذي
يقصد بذلك الحقيقه ان هذه المعلومات جدا
قديمه لكن الفرق الان بعد اكتشاف الانجي
اس اللي هو الجيل الثالث من السيكونس
للدين ايضا موجود ذاته كبيره واستطاعوا
بعض العلماء انهم يسوون تحليل لهذه
النتائج اضافوا عليها مثل البيبر منشور
الان يمكن اكثر من 300
سيكونسينج استطاعوا يحددون ان اصل البشر
بشكل عام هو حقيقه في عبارات سابقه ذكره
اثيوبيا عموم اثيوبيا او السودان هي بنفس
المنطقه
الهيكل العظمي بشري متكامل في اثيوبيا هلا
مؤخر الاثار بس من ناحيه جينيه انا اتكلم
من الناحيه دينيه لما سووا انا لسه جميع
السكونس على المستوى العالم في اكثر من
300 سيكونس
بسوفت وير معين يسوي انا لسه يحدد لكم
التشابه اللي يسمونه
فهذه التشابه ادى تاكيد المعلومات انها
لكن المره هذه ما قالوا تيوب قالوا
السودان وهي قريبه من بعض لكن هو معروف
علميا ان اصلا البشر من طبعا انا اتكلم عن
ادم الثنائي اللي هو اكثر من ثلاثه مليون
سنه وما تتكلم عن النبي ادم اللي هو 7,3
او 10,000 سنه وبالتالي بدايه البشر كشر
همم في منطقه السودان او منطقه كيوبيا طيب
وكمان احنا بدنا نعرف بالنسبه لتحديد
السلاله هل هو يرتبط اكثر باصل الام ولا
الاب يعني ايضا يتجاهل
يعني ما عن طريق الام اللي هو باستخدام
المايكندري دي ان اي لان نيويورك فقط من
الام او استخدام الوايكروميزومز لهنود من
الاب فقط ايضا فيد ميوكولاس دي ان المخلوط
ممكن
من الام من الاب يسوون دراسات معينه بحيث
انهم يحددون مايكروسوفت او همم
معين او كوبي نمبر
بحيث يعطيك
في المنطقه الفلانيه الان في في ماركه
معين خاص بالروس يعني اي انسان تلقى فيه
ماركه هذا فيكون هذا تابع لعرق الروسي
وهكذا طبعا في ابحاث كثيره همم لتاكيد بعض
المعلومات طيب ما فائده هكذا دراسات كان
دراسه جامعه اكسفورد لكلاكم كبحثين لرسم
خريطه الجنيه في العالم ومن الناحيه
الطبيه يعني طبعا اله تستخدم
للجنائيه بالجرائم على ذلك ايضا طبيا مهم
جدا لان الان كثير من الادويه تشتغل على
الريس معين او عرق معين اخر وبالتالي همم
يصنعون ادويه يسمونه سمارت في الجسم
الادويه الذكيه بحيث انه يكون دواء معين
خاص بسلاله معينه او خاص بعرق معين
بالاضافه
او دواء معين يشتغل على شخص وما يشتغل على
الشخص الاخر
باكتشافات هذه وتحديد المركبات من كل
انسان ممكن يصمونه دواء يعني بكره تروح
المستشفى ما يعطيك يعطيك
الجماعات وتدريسها في المستقبل الى اي حد
يمكن ان يحد من العنصريه بين البشر
مثلا من سلاله واحده
يزيد الوعي يعني الناس اللي يقراون
ويتعلموا غير متخصصين في الاخير يصلي سوف
يجدن الخالق واحد واحنا تقريبا نفس واحده
فما في فرق اللهم فقط بالظاهر شكرا جزيلا
حدثنا هنا في الاستديو الدكتور همم عبد
الله المطيري استاذ عن الجينات هو التطور
في جامعه الشارقه شكرا دكتور نورتنا